a descendants for i feel like could
totally happen but also a spin-off could
happen with new
um new characters and new daughters and
sons of princesses and princes and other
villains like
you really have endless possibilities
there
[Music]
girl most people are having a hard time
even cooking
a meal during this covent routine but
you're serving up a brand new song and
music
video thank you yeah you know what i'm
myself
having trouble with like the small
things like cooking my own meal but
here we go we i guess we're released to
music now
this is such a fun single even the stars
is already such a
summer jam um talk to me about your
decision to to
release music especially at a time when
we need something happy right now
yeah you know i it's always been a goal
of mine
on music and and create um
and rock mafia approached me after the
wild surprising success of queen of mean
and asked if i wanted to work together
again and
i think they're massively talented and
they've worked with people who i admire
and so it just kind of felt like a
natural organic decision and you know we
recorded this back in november and then
kind of sat on it for a while and i
think the timing just ended up working
out really
well it was like kismet kind of
um yeah it we shot the video during
the pandemic we released it during the
pandemic it's like
it all just kind of fit together and i
think it's such an important message
right now i think you know so many
people are obviously struggling it's
such a strange time
i myself i'm having trouble navigating
it so yeah i feel like it's
it's nice to bring some levity to the
world right now
and i loved the music video and it's
crazy that you actually shot it
during the pandemic but you're just
alone rocking out in a field so you are
social distancing
100 it's like it was so crazy going into
it they were like
well we first had this this other
concept our director mills and hales
have this beautiful like
big concept with dancers and this and
that and
um it was also really cool but we
obviously had to reconsider
um once kovitz struck so
we reworked it and it had to be outside
and it had to be like a very small crew
so we did just that and you know
everyone was wearing face masks and
and face shields and gloves and there
were
sanitization stations like that is such
a mouthful
sanitization stations everywhere um
and it it felt safe i have to say i
think they did a great job so
there's a little peek into what it's
going to be like when hollywood reopens
i think
well i think the last time i checked
queen of mean is certified gold
it is yeah it went certified gold i
actually just got my plaque in the mail
like
last week um which is so cool it's so
i'm proud of it and i'm excited and it's
just
it's a really cool like memento to have
for sure
where are you going to put it i think in
my
like entertainment room i feel like that
makes sense you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you and i talked shortly after the music
video went live and it had like
i want to say just a couple million
views at the time and now it's almost
at 270 million views like what
insane totally could not have predicted
that
i just yeah i feel like the descendants
fans
are so dedicated and lovely and
um loyal and then i guess we just you
know it
seemingly people from all over sort of
tuned in
so yeah i feel very very grateful for
that
while we're on the the topic of
descendants i just want to offer my
heart out to you because i know that
it was last week the the year
anniversary of
cameron's passing um how are you feeling
it's been a year
it's still so surreal to even process
that but
is there a memory of cameron that really
keeps you going
there are i mean there are countless
memories i feel so lucky to have
to have known him and create such
special
memories and moments with him um i i
couldn't even just pick one
i i feel like his his spirit is so alive
and
always will be and i i have pictures of
him up and framed and everything
and you know i keep in touch with the
cast and you know
we like to check in on each other and
it's it just
his passing obviously had a profound
impact on so many people and
um yeah it's just it reminded me to hold
the people i love
very close for sure and i just like
i i think about his family so much and
um
just really really miss him
do you think that a descendant's four is
even possible
moving forward or or do you think maybe
like a spin-off could be in the works
what are your thoughts on yeah
i feel like it's just such a cool world
that
they created um there are so many
different
possibilities i mean a descendant's four
i feel like could totally happen but
also a spin-off could happen with new
um new characters and new daughters and
sons of princesses and princes and other
villains like
you really have endless possibilities
there but
i will forever be grateful for
descendants and the
family i made there and the experiences
i had so
i would love to do something definitely
well audrey's already had such an
amazing arc over the first three movies
we've seen her
uh pretty much tackle everything what do
you
like to imagine that could be next for
her
well i think that she's sort of like you
said she's kind of gone through
everything she's been the mean girl
she's been like the heartbroken girl
and she i just want to see her sort of
be friends with people if that were to
if audrey were to exist in another
um iteration of descendants or another
movie i would
i think that it would be nice for her to
finally be like a gal pal like just
be nice right just be nice and cool like
i think that would be awesome
i want to just be like easy breezy
audrey yeah me too we haven't that's
like one of the few things we haven't
seen yet so
that would be really fun yeah like a
proper girl's
sleepover fun time like girl power yeah
for sure
[Music]
totes
you